we're doing well say hello to Gary Vee
and what are your thoughts so far hey
Joe when did the last girl hand the
radio down here on my under the last
call in from Joe was I was driving and
Gary was making me super uncomfortable
because he was saying stop complaining
but I love complaining and I live my
life complaining and it just hit me Joe
I love you so much you you don't
understand this is the biggest thing for
me like I've already made my thing I'm
gonna buy the New York Jets and it'll be
a movie and it's gonna be great at this
at this point Joe this this phonecall
means the world to me you have to
understand why this matters if you
actually believe what you just said if
this is not a fleeting moment of the
energy of this show and you're able to
maintain that feeling you cannot imagine
how much better your life is going to be
it's easy to complain complaining is the
easy way out negativity is the easy way
out you're lucky if you're gorgeous but
if you break up break if you eat like
crap and don't take care of yourself and
do drugs and drink alcohol you'll not
look gorgeous you're lucky if you're 6
foot 11 and can sprint like like you
know a gazelle but if you don't work on
your craft and you work on your outside
jumper if you don't work on your
intensity and your endurance you won't
be an NBA player so yes I got lucky that
I can win the game of life and
entrepreneurship but I put in the work
for the last 25 years minimum ly and
maybe even longer to be the best version
of myself at this thing